two annual candy lecture at this
I want to thank begin by thanking being
part of the family support this lecture
and salvation studies at Yale the
lecture on today this time on Gandhi's
birthday is a moment for us to reflect
on the life and work of Mandi and the
lessons one can draw from it I'm
particularly delighted to welcome
fellows neurology back to Yale and in
many ways fellows is perhaps exemplifies
a several of the features of Gandhi's
life in Korea Gandhi started out as a
lawyer he first went to Bombay and and
was faced with a lack of success in the
courts in his biography he talks about
how his voice dried up and he couldn't
speak and in a way he left for South
Africa in search of greener pastures
representing the first generation of
Indian professionals were migrating to
Africa Gandhi its career in South Africa
moved from that of a commercial lawyer
to being someone who spoke increasingly
about the interests of the Indians who
employed him and then more broadly about
the wider community of Indians and later
on about other populations as well in
some ways a Gandhi was the first started
lawyer in Africa and he fought to get
admitted before the bar and many of
those challenges come from the
experience of being someone who moves
between two worlds are representing his
clients but also his race in the
courtroom it is it it is indeed a
pleasure to bring fellows in in the year
2017 the year he completes 50 years of
practice in the court of Kenya Pharaohs
is an advocate in the High Court of
Kenya at the High Court of Tanzania and
the High Court of Zanzibar
he has also practiced in Uganda and the
Seychelles his education reflects the
sort of diversity of sights
he studied in Bombay in London at the
bar at Lincoln's Inn and New Haven at
Yale Law School by 8:00 in his LLM in
1974 a ferocious legal practice
spans several years but I wanted to
highlight a series of matters he got
involved in from the 1980s onwards
well he sort of became the face of the
other the lawyer for the pro-democracy
in Kenya that was chugging against
one-party dictatorship and
authoritarianism he appeared in numerous
cases defending opposition politicians
newspapers investigating and for this
work he was he has been recognized in
multiple forums he was given the
International Commission of Jewish
support for the 1995 he received the
bernhard simon's human rights prize he
was on the Law Society of Kenya role of
honor the Indian government gave him the
privacy part is someone in 2007 and the
Maasai people gave him the safeguarding
Rights Awards also in 2007 Gandhi's
other the other role was that of a
writer and a publicist and starting from
adjacent South Africa he wrote
extensively both as a correspondent to
individuals through letters but
published and wrote a number of
magazines newspapers and and created a
kind of vibrant of mode of discussion
fellows himself has been a has a long
career as a writer journalist and a
publicist his span of writings range
from works on human rights in Africa on
the role of the press and media freedom
on detailed commentary on political
affairs in Kenya and other parts of
Africa and as well as literally
interests in fiction and poetry Gandhi's
ideas also were not just that of a
liberal lawyer in a courtroom but at a
certain point of time also began to
challenge the entire framework of
liberal legality in some ways he makes a
break from the idea of the law and hence
Farraj very sort of condemns the law
medicine and railways and instruments
that support colonial rule in some ways
Feroz his own career shows both someone
reflects someone who acts through the
framework of human rights but it's also
careful and critical of many of the
assumptions that undergird its framework
and this comes through several of his
conversations and interviews are
available online so for instance when
there were claims that multiparty
democracy arrived in Africa in the 1918
the 1990s a result of ending of the
he pointed out that this ignores a very
long struggle that exists within Africa
for democracy and for representative
institutions doing right back to the
founding of the African National
Congress in the early 20th century
similarly he pointed out that you cannot
run human rights activism based only on
foreign aid it is something that has to
grow indigenously has something that has
to develop local roots and has to become
a principle of lived fairness and not
just a seminar that I run run run out
run out of Tears
lastly furrows plays a really important
role in thinking about the role of
Asians in Africa I am hesitant to
describe Pharaoh as an Indian lawyer
because what he is is an African lawyer
as we in the United States I grapple
around the question of what it means to
be a hyphenated identity
I think Pharaoh's death throws his life
and experience to tell us what it is to
sort of reverse the - in another part of
the world
afros has played a critical role in
documenting the history of South Asians
in East Africa he has been the head of
the Asian African heritage trust and
curated sort of path-breaking exhibition
on the Asian Diaspora in Africa he is
the author of several important works of
history including one of the first
biographies of pure gamma pinto this
sort of go and revolutionary he was part
of the Kenyan national struggle most
recently I mean in ferocious sort of
stellar career Feroz was in the news as
the lawyer appearing before the Kenyan
Supreme Court representing rural or
dinga and other opposition parties where
he managed to convince the court to
successfully overturn the recent results
a presidential election and order new
elections in some ways as a historic
moment has happened only three times in
world history Kenya is the most recent
one
Fira was welcomed back to Yale we very
much look forward to
[Applause]
doctor proven but members of the but
family the Council of the South Asian
Studies Council Harry the Macmillan
Center for International and area
studies professor day thank you for
having me it's a pleasure being back the
title of the lecture is and it's a
descriptive title gaudy and Kenya from
1919 to 1929 and it was subtitled an
unlikely theater of operations for Gaudi
the this period 1919 to 1929 is a
pivotal period in Gardez career it was
in this decade that he changed from a
diasporic hero leading a struggle for
equal rights and equal treatment of
Indians abroad as subjects in the Empire
and against white supremists in South
Africa into an Indian leader of a
struggle for independent for the
independence of India and the end of
colonialism Kenya was an unlikely field
for this transformation some at that in
in the late in the early 1980s I was
given a photograph of Gandhi in Zanzibar
and my curiosity and reading took me
forward to his return to India 19 for 15
and a search for the retention of any
ties with the continent that's Africa in
1919 it was a
time for the clarification of his own
political objectives and those of the
Indian National Congress beginning to
bring into focus a direction for 300
million people and then in that search
within the Khilafat movement within the
prospect of the an intended satyagraha
in the aftermath of the indigo
satyagraha the ending of the indentured
labourers this is all between 1917 1919
and so on
he saw also a political opportunity
emerge in Kenya Kenya was then classic
gaudy terrain Indian settlers white
supremists true oppressive legislation
exclusionary policies official
humiliation of Indians the distant
Emperor's repeated concern for all his
subjects in that he considered that he
should take up the fight for equal
rights for Indians in Kenya as he had in
Natal and the trans law but there was
another and a more important reason to
understand this interest in Kenya
hitherto absent in Gandhi one must
recall that the main political issue in
India at this time was not independence
it was the push for equal rights for
Indians while remaining subjects of the
Empire so in the same year 1919 for
example gadi was asked to write a new
constitution
for the Indian National Congress in his
draft of the proposed Constitution he
set out the Congress's goal and it was
Swaraj within the Empire
India's expectations in this regard were
heightened by the huge part it played in
the defense of the empire in the
recently ended war 1.25 million Indian
troops took part in the first world war
this involvement was not less than the
lauded Canadian Australian and South
African dominions that of those
dominions and thus India's demand was
for similar Dominion status within the
Empire that it also had helped to end
the the conflict victoriously reforms to
constitutional advance and in the
franchise as well were sought which
would move India to it's self-government
and equal treatment within India gadi
was not in disagreement with these goals
but on the issue of the priority
attaching to Congress's objectives he
considered the main issue to be amongst
all these to be the Equality of the
treatment of Indians in British
territories outside India God he
considered that redress through other
aims through through Swaraj through
Dominion status through the the
constitutional reforms would be and I
quote a pious hope doomed to
disappointment
unless ignorances replaced
at the center by wisdom and apathy by
sympathy for the claims of Indians
living in His Majesty's dominions
outside India God he kept raising the
question of the status of Indians in
South Africa at that time just at the
beginning of 1919 as quote again as a
matter of no small importance and
finally an editorial in the young Indian
young and in young India his magazine
his weekly placed that issue of as of
more importance than even the all
absorbing question of reforms these are
the constitutional reforms this is how
he concluded the the issue according to
the above test or feeling for the
weakest of ourselves as a measure of our
capacity for self-government this
question of our countrymen in South
Africa is of more immediate importance
than even the all-absorbing question of
reforms that was the outlook of an
Indian politician who had spent 21 years
in South Africa and 1 and a half years
I'm sorry a little more four years in
India itself in the political arena in a
congruence of consequence the same
issues coming to
respect is more recognizable to us today
as the color bar it was a term that
Gaudi used in South Africa and also
later in India national respect and what
he was handling at that moment in this
respectful phraseology was calibre and
the color bar was begins to play a
sharper role as we go into the events in
Kenya and for immigration rights this
was the package of equal treatment and
those struggles against the racist
settler presence abetted by a colonial
governor and his administration who were
more sympathetic with the settlers all
these the the confrontation between the
Indian Kenya Indian politicians the
settlers the government and London all
these were at an advanced stage in Kenya
with the imperial government in London
already also involved and a
determination of this question by the
Imperial Government in London was in the
offing to gaudí this presented an
opportunity firstly these were also
exactly the battles that Gandhi had
identified and then fought in South
Africa for 21 years these were exactly
apart from immigration the battles that
Congress was now identifying as India's
next step but more intriguingly Gandhi
was also becoming emotionally involved
he would fight this one not to obtain
any privileges for Indians in Kenya but
to secure the rights they should have
from being whittled down and more to
prevent another white supremacist
Dominion in Africa something that was
also looming in nearby Southern Rhodesia
and something he had failed to do in
South Africa he would prevent another
substantial Indian population falling
under a formally white racial government
this - he had failed to do in South
Africa his view now was that this was an
opportunity for India in respect of the
issues of equal treatment and national
respect and this is the reasoning for if
Indians in a British colony in the
Empire in Africa succeeded in winning
equal treatment with British settlers
there then the principle of equal
treatment within the Empire would be one
throughout the Empire including English
was shared by the Working Committee of
Congress and Congress itself now it is
important to realize if these events
which are taking place in 1919 and these
are gaudy views in 1919 it is if these
events were taking place within the neck
after five years
Gandhi's word in the Working Committee
war was total his control over Congress
was total but in 1919 he did not command
this amount of power really within
Congress and so when I say that this was
a view shared by the Working Committee
it is a working committee which was not
composed of people he had put there
Tillich is still alive and there are the
sea
the senior leaders within Congress still
very much in control of the Congress
gadi is a 40-plus newcomer respected but
yet to prove himself in 1919 and the
years that follow 2021 are the beginning
of as he himself says I showed that I
could be useful to the Congress and so
he was now putting forward views that he
had to convince the leaders about
fortunately or unfortunately they too
saw it as an opportunity to win equal
rights for Indians everywhere including
India by winning the battle in Kenya the
fight against the weak offerings really
of an ungrateful crown in the form of
the Montagu chamfered reforms now this
is what is going on in India and events
such as the Jallianwala Bagh massacre
April 1919 the Rowlett acts the crawling
orders the Punjab's sedition cases would
continue in India so what Gaudi was
saying was that South Africa should have
priority East Africa now should have
priority not that the other objectives
should should be abandoned but gaudy and
Congress now considered that the Indian
struggles in Kenya were an opportunity
to progress to success on the equal
treatment front so that Kenya was not
only of relevance but qualified for
Congress's intervention and mobilization
in Kenya reflecting this thinking the
Congress supporter cf Andrews but they
put this thinking in this way the
question of equal treatment in India
will be tried in the colonies
this is how they their approach was
rajagopalachari recalled later after
1923 but for the Congress the decision
on the Kenya Indians demands for equal
treatment was the acid test because it
would it would enable the same demand to
go through more easily in India now
ironically the Congress view was
confirmed by the white settlers own
viewpoint in opposition this the
Congress view that success for the
Indians in Kenya would mean successful
India itself was precisely one of the
grounds of opposition by the settlers
and a ground for actually the the
removal of the Indian presence in Kenya
through the immigration laws
the governor quarantine in his cable in
February of 1923 are moving a little
ahead to the new colonial secretary
Devonshire set out the settler view does
any quote any real victory for the
Indian race in Africa we will mean
similar very probably even larger claims
in British Guiana Fiji and possibly
elsewhere not accepting Nutter or even
India itself so that this Congress
policy is a is a real motor
which moved Congress to intervene in
Kenya which impel which which actually
will that intervention being led by
Gandhi and CF Andrews Reverend Andrews
in there now the settlers scale were
were immediately at after the war as the
Kenya Indians demands reemerged after
1918 moved quickly in respect of two
things there was unity among the white
settler organizations to present a memo
a memorandum to the Colonial Office in
London and in this memorandum the
settler leaders Delamare and others said
were set out the reasons why Indians
should not get any parity in relation to
the franchise or to the white Highlands
and so on and amongst these was the the
the the view of the settlers that these
Indian settlers were not hygienic enough
that their morals were terrible and that
their influence upon the the country was
not not really a favorable one for the
country itself immediately after that
the government then said they were going
to present going to look into the
economic aspects and the economic
Commission the Kapiti Commission on on
the economic aspects in Kenya was then
set in
so it was it was very clear to the
settlers that this was not a a Kenyan
municipal conflict this was a conflict
which would have ramifications through
the whole of Africa and particularly in
South Africa throughout the empire and
in in India itself
gadi responded now when I say gaudy I do
mean gaudy because it is not a euphemism
for Congress or or this was a a person
who had was highly respected because he
had already led his except sorry his
experience of leading political
struggles against white supremacist
governments and movements had already
been tested and admired that his
experience of satyagraha in South Africa
on these issues was respected that he
his judgment on these aspects had been
lauded by by go clay and so on so he was
an active leader in this respect and he
sent Andrews there on arrival at Mombasa
Andrews himself in here in his in the
welcoming ceremony said said ceremony
said quote I have been specially asked
by mr. Gandhi to come out to Africa and
I had done so at first with very great
reluctance because most urgent and
pressing matters were called were
calling me to remain in
India and also a little later
mr. abdul rasul allah the novice ROMs
son who was the then president of the
Indian Association sent a telegram to
Gandhi quote Indian Association records
deep heartfelt gratitude for sparing mr.
Andrews from Punjab The Andrews arrived
in December 1919 and began a series he
was an extremely conscientious and
extremely industrious worker for Gandhi
he entered in immediately into a large
number of interviews and travels with in
Kenya and his integrity his independence
of mind was highly respected he
interviewed across the political
opinions and so on and in 1920 a little
in June of 1920 published privately his
book Indians in Kenya he rebutted all
the arguments of this memorandum and the
Economic Commission report from the
settlers he pointed out the conflict of
interest of having the same persons in
in reporting as if they were independent
people in the economic Commission and so
on and all these were the these
rebuttals were reflected in and
published in young India gothy had taken
over young India after the Bombay
Chronicle and Horniman had been deported
and used it in in precisely the way he
had done Indian of
in South Africa the in relation to this
the apart from rebutting the the issues
on the morals of the Indians and their
poor hygiene the major issue was
immigration and what the settlers wanted
was a push that enabled the the statutes
to contain enough powers for the
arbitrary deportation of persons already
within the country and the arbitrary
refusal of persons entering into the
country and of course this was targeted
solely at the Indian immigration things
now this issue of immigration was not
again a Kenya matter by this time they
were about 1.2 million Indians overseas
throughout the empire firstly under
indentured labor from 1838 onwards and
of private emigration mostly of
merchants and their the settlements were
from Fiji in the East the the South
Pacific Malaya the coming in to to
Mauritius South Africa reunion and then
into the West Indies and so any if the
the right to to control Indian
immigration by the dominions was not an
abstract right it was a right targeted
against the presence and the increasing
presence of Indians and so in the
in the UM in the Commonwealth the
Dominions had held a conference in which
this issue was extremely prominent and
the the Dominions particularly pushed by
by South Africa but very quietly but as
as insistently by Australia on their
white Australia plank and the Canadians
as well to to make sure that the right
of the Dominions to control immigration
was independent of London and the
imperial cabinet that was established
and the settlers in Kenya were using
this right to say that that is perfect
that what we are asking is not only
lawful but is the the statutory
provision throughout the the Empire
Andrews rebutted this by showing that
within the decisions made at the
Commonwealth dominions conference was a
provision that British Indian citizens
already domiciled in a self-governing
colony shall receive as far as possible
equal treatment so this was going on and
Andrews was the the voice of the
overseas Indians and the the this was
conveyed to gaudí and Gandhi did to use
this information in two directions one
through young India as as a journal of
record and secondly conveying this
material and the rebuttals and the
statutory qualifications etc to persons
of influence in Britain
by now by the by 2021
Garvey had had gathered a large amount
of influence in British public opinion
makers in Britain among these were
sympathetic members of parliament there
were Church missionary bodies CMS LMS
and so on and Andrews came from the
missionary bodies so that God II had
contacts and was able to to convey these
views in deep into the British circles
decision-making circles when these
matters when these reports came in in
young India gadi commented on the
material that Andrew sent and one of the
major things of course was the removal
of undesirables bill 1919 and that of
course as I said was aimed directly at
Indian immigration and if this passed
then they the there were no reasons no
reasons need be given by the governor
for for deporting any person or of
refusing entry to any person and this is
so Andrew sent a telegram to Gandhi
saying that the bill is now been
published this is what Gandhi says
hardly any comment is necessary on this
cablegram
there is a dead set against the Indian
settler in East Africa the proposed
ordinance the statute is in my humble
opinion more most mischievous in
character
and leaves every Indian at the mercy of
an executive subservient to the
interested European agitator against the
Indians the unscrupulous nature of the
agitation is manifest from the utterly
false charges I regard the proposed
ordinance as the first definite legal
step towards the reduction of the
Indians to complete survey leti he has
dared to claim an equal status with the
recently arrived European settler he has
dared to dispute the haughty position
taken up by his European rival and trade
the latter has captured the executive I
mentioned this in connection with what I
submitted earlier was the emotional
attachment displayed by gaudí in his
response to the events that are going on
in Kenya and the conduct of the white
settlers God is disliked for his settler
opponents as well as their politics is
again reflected in his sharp responses
only just short of open rudeness the
situation was one that Gandhi had
regularly faced in South Africa but
there he had not made such responses
such comments there he had rationally
rebutted such positions in his
publication Indian opinion and are often
moved to negotiations such as the gaudy
Smuts agreement in the Kenya case he
does not do so directly or indirectly
through Andrews or London he is clear
that he will not do so this is how he
continues that comment quote the East
African position admits of no compromise
such as was possible in South Africa
where the condition was totally
different from the East African
condition but Gotti does not give any
reason or reasons
why he says so nor why and how the
condition is totally different
preventing him from following the path
he had followed before and after without
such reasons it is an odd statement to
make this is not Gandhi's normal course
of conduct the guardian pact for example
of later years very soon also shows this
I venture to suggest that the emotional
engagement and great dislike were
bringing this about a situation which
Gaudi himself would have considered
unworthy of a true sati agree this
extensive reportage and concern about
immigration reflected the intense push
by the white settlers to create to clear
the way to realize their wish for
self-rule where the only stumbling block
was the presence of the Indians and
their political agitation against it and
for equal rights but both could be
removed by the enactment of this
ordinance and these were now the issues
that were going for decision to London
by the Imperial Government the very
issues that would bring equal treatment
to India and in in 1922 end of 1922 and
early in 1923 matters came to a head as
the colonial secretary who until then
was Winston Churchill changed to Lord
Devin sure with the change of government
from liberal to conservatives and the
new colonial secretary called a
deputation of the settlers to come and
address it speak to him about it he also
called an Indian Kenya Indian
allegation and he also called an Indian
Indian delegation and he also called the
Government of India delegation and
Andrews went as part of the Indian
Indian delegation the churches were
involved and so on and this was the the
push to a determination of the
contending forces within Kenya on 25th
July 1923 the new colonial secretary
finally issued the white paper Indians
in Kenya and his decision was set out as
follows on those contentious questions
quote this is the famous declaration
primarily Kenya is an African Cantera
Tory and his Majesty's Government think
it is necessary definitely to record
their considered opinion that the
interest of the African natives must be
paramount and that if and when those
interests and the interests of the
immigrant races should conflict the
former should prevail but in the
administration of Kenya His Majesty's
Government regard themselves as
exercising a trust on behalf of the
African population and they are unable
to delegate or share this trust the
object of which may be defined as the
protection and advancement of the native
races this is the famous command paper
I'll first speak on the reaction in
India and then on the reaction in Kenya
in India the declaration came as a shock
the declaration came and I quote
rajagopalachari as as a shock because
for Congress and other Indian political
opinion the decision on the Kenya
Indians demands for equal treatment were
the acid test
this is a repetition of what I said
earlier this reaction in India showed
the key importance that Congress and the
struggle in India had attached to the
Indian settler conflict in it Kenya the
reaction reflected the then given view
that the conflict in Kenya would resolve
the ongoing issues of equality and
national respect in India itself the
decision was seen therefore not just as
a decision on Indians in Kenya but as a
decision on Indians throughout the
Empire and on Indians in India itself
rajagopalachari continues quote the
imperial parliament has accepted the
cabinet decision on Kenya which lays
down a general policy for the whole
empire so that India and Congress had
seen from 1919 onwards under the
leadership of gothy and of his own
conviction that the struggle there and
the decision on it would lay down a
general policy for the whole empire when
the white paper was published
gadi was in prison he had been sentenced
in I think 1921 or 2022 and remained in
prison till 1924 in his absent
rajagopalachari was acting as the editor
of young India and young India carried
three editorials on the devonshire
Declaration in August again in August
and again in September and also carried
Andrews report on the consequences of
Kenya historian Robert Gregory was
written on India and East Africa
concluded I quote in India
the chief effect of the Devonshire
declaration was to disillusion the
moderate wing as to the value of
retaining a close association with
Britain
mr. Shastri who was a government of
India appointment for Indians overseas
saw the cabinet decision and I quote as
a profound humiliation and the deepest
affront to India again
rajagopalachari it is to the moderates
that the meaning of Kenya has come with
the shock of stupefaction the comforting
postulates on which they had built up
their political philosophy have been
destroyed to them indeed Kenya was the
acid test he repeats himself
India has no place in the Empire and the
Empire can have no place for India so
the devonshire declaration a step in
Kenya's history was the trigger in
bringing about a sea change in India's
history and moving from equality within
the Empire to the unification of huge
numbers of Indians behind the demand for
a break with the Empire and complete
independence when we speak about
moderates we are not referring to
persons more moderate than Gandhi
although Gandhi is leader of sui generis
the the contrasts were the extremists
so-called such as Bhagat Singh and those
who felt that it was important not to
eliminate the use of violence in the
struggle for freedom but moderates
involved all the persons who were then
leaders in Congress and it was this
that the Devonshire declaration shook
this block and so this is how Congress
reacted in September 23rd remember that
the Devonshire declarations of July July
25th Congress convened a special session
at Delhi to debate the Kenya issue in
fact and quote a resolution urging
separation from the British Empire was
moved but it was rejected by gaudí
moti Lal Nehru and other elder statesmen
who were still not prepared to commit
Congress to a final break this is Hugh
tinker the again
rajagopalachari speaking for God II
through young India in another editorial
says the meaning of Kenya is a challenge
the challenge to make ourselves free and
the ourselves are Indian Indians Lord
reading Viceroy also warned London of
this effect
he said indignation and disappointment
is shared by all classes and parties in
India including those who have usually
been our strong supporters to stay
within the Empire I doubt whether you or
her His Majesty's Government realized
the national humiliation which is
implied in the decision I trust that you
and His Majesty's Government understand
the difficulty in future of impressing
upon the Indians the benefit they
derived from associating with the Empire
they were immediately after the dementia
declaration for about a year
steps were taken to ameliorate - to
renegotiate to ask the
the government to change the mind Gandhi
took no significant part in these post
decision discussions but he continued to
publish major articles in young India on
Kenya in the years that followed firstly
for the rest of 1923 and then 24 25 26
as examples of this in 1923 he writes
these are articles by Andrews the Kenya
Highlands covering the flogging and
torture to death of a settlers employee
the white man's trust on forced labor
and Hut tax in India again 1923 African
labor in Kenya again 20 1920 Kenya and
Kilimanjaro on settler plans to extend
settler dominations into Tanganyika
despite it being a mandated territory
hairy to coo of Kenya the lowlands of
Kenya miscarriage of justice in Kenya so
that although the the decision had come
out in 19min 1923 gadi did not stop
although did not stop publishing the the
and exposing it was a spotlight upon
settler and colonial government
misconduct in Kenya and he continued
doing that although now Congress gaudy
Andrews Tagore all of the the the
leadership is changing in moving away
now from the settlement of equal
treatment in India by reference to
struggles in Kenya and elsewhere by 1928
Congress's view of a break with Britain
had become part of its formal and
publicly stated policy and now see
motilal nehru who was president of
congress of the congress that year
stated in his presidential address that
the best way they could help indians
overseas was to take action to gain our
freedom here the same person who in 1923
and the same people who same leadership
who in 1923 were not willing to make a
break were now in the in these years had
shifted totally over and Congress was
now committed to the to this and just to
give you a much later statement but more
acts as explicit in 1936 jamala Nehru in
his report to Congress it says quote our
countrymen abroad must realize that the
key to their problems lies in India they
rise or they fall with the rise and fall
of India and that was the exact opposite
of what the 1919 1920 1921 22 and 23
position was that they that India would
rise and fall with the rise and fall in
in the colonies particularly South
Africa and Kenya but more specially in
Kenya so these were the the reactions
and what we see is this that these
positions affected I'm sorry that the
Devonshire declaration affected India
Britain relations and thereby Indian
history took a new direction and if that
happened by reason of Kenya's history
gaudy and Congress had not been helping
the Kenya in Indians achieved their
political goals this was Congress acting
in Indian politics to achieve India's
own political goals I turned to the
reaction in Kenya the Kenyan Indians had
fought for two goes
firstly for equal rights and secondly
against settler self-rule they failed in
the first they did
not get equal rights and because the law
and settler attitudes did not change nor
did they need to be changed immediately
the Indians thought that date had failed
in the second goal as well they thought
that this that thus they had totally
lost that they had won nothing that they
sustained opposition had achieved
nothing but history renders another
verdict one that that sustained
opposition and Gerdes had denied
self-rule to the white settlers and two
that the success of the Kenya Indians in
denying self-rule to the settlers was
the biggest achievement of the political
activity of the Indians in pre
independent Kenya the white settlers saw
this clearly and a historian Mary Brown
writing on Kenya deemed it a crushing
rebuff to the settlers so that the the
the conclusion that emerged out of the
Devonshire declaration took a bigger
impact on India and a lesser impact on
Kenya and although if I may sum up what
happened in Kenya by reason of it the
Kenya Indian political struggling with
in Kenya had ensured ultimately that
Kenya did not go the southern Rhodesian
Zimbabwean way with a UDI by the white
settler population used to formal
self-rule and a civil war and
independence delayed by twenty years or
more it prevented secondly of
Federation of white colonies in East in
Africa again on the model of the Central
African Federation and thirdly it
delayed Union of white South Africa
white Central Africa and white East
Africa into becoming another reality it
delayed it and thereby made it
politically unviable as African
nationalism pushed began to push there a
second response by the Kenya Indians
also involved in gaudy and Congress as a
result of the Devonshire declaration the
East African Indian National Congress
resolved that the Kenyan Indians would
suspend payment of the poll tax until
the dev ensured decisions were modified
a resolution against this was tabled at
the next annual meeting of the East
African Congress at Mombasa quote in
view of the unjust and ubiquitous Kenya
decision of the 25th July Congress
resolves that as a protest against the
main decision payment of poll tax by
Indians in Kenya accepting government
servants should be suspended as a first
step until the modification of the said
decisions now following on this
resolution which was passed
overwhelmingly it was decided also to
organize a satyagraha against the poll
tax law to that end
mr. ma Desai the foremost political
leader of the Indians in Kenya till
today
travelled to India for support and again
God is young India reports this his
efforts quote the local Indian leaders
had thought of starting this satyagraha
as a form of direct action against the
Kenya government decision MA decide the
Indians leader put this idea before a
meeting of the Working Committee held at
sub Amity in the end of November
19:23 the committee seemed to be quite
skeptical about the advisability of
starting such a movement and again mr.
rajagopalachari cross-examined mr. Desai
at length about the number of people
that would be involved the probable
amount of suffering they would have to
undergo the morale of the Indians in
Kenya and similar points
mr. Desai placed before the Working
Committee the information that he had
and wanted advice from them the
committee definitely refused to give any
advice on this point and decided to send
one of their representatives to Kenya to
attend the Congress East African Indian
Congress and to study the situation the
the Working Committee thus did not
consider the Kenyan Indians sufficiently
prepared for an effective satyagraha
though there were those on the committee
who was sympathetic to the idea of
assistance to them and it sets out
several Indian Canyon Indians went to
prison for this and the satyagraha ever
took place
that is how Suraj Annina Luke first came
to Kenya and took the president ship of
the Congress in January 1925 the
devonshire declaration moved the Kenyan
Indians political activity into a new
dimension it diluted the the not only
the intensity of their political work
but it brought disunity into the the
Indian Congress East African Indian
Congress aparts which through their
resulting confusion brought about by the
declaration the failure of the intended
satyagraha and the change in Congress
policy in Kenya because now as the yes
the Congress in India moved into other
directions
total Swaraj total independence break
with Britain Kenya was no longer part of
the agenda although it every single year
li annual Congress the issue of overseas
Indians was always on the agenda and
resolutions were always passed but that
that intense push by Guardian Congress
from 1919 to 23 was no longer present
but the direction was charted for them
by Sarojini Naidu in the in her
President's speech this is what she said
to the East African Indians quote the
future lies with the Africans but your
part is not to betray them by betraying
your rights and though there was no
further direct Indian involvement in
Kenyan affairs by Congress till 1947 it
brought about shared political activity
between Africans and Indians in Kenya in
the coming decades although there was no
major Indian political activity saved by
individuals like Bo Pinto or Mack insane
shed influence arose between them and
and over the years and one of them was
importantly the example and the ideals
of the Indian independence movement
which I'll come to in a while and the
giardiniera assault on the concept of
colonialism the I come to the time after
the Devonshire declaration after 1925
now and because the the what was
happening was as the the intensity of
the independence struggle in India grew
by 1929 godís focus had moved completely
away from the colonies from Africa 1930
was the dandy March 1931 was a round
table and then a continuous succession
of crises right up to quit India and
finally the partition and so Gaudi did
not look back to to Africa again but
there are postscripts to warm our hands
on when in two years later from 1929 in
1931 when Kenyatta returned to England
in May 1931 to present views to the
British Parliament's Joint Select
Committee on closer Union he met up with
Andrews by then in Britain
both men were frequent visitors to the
house of William MacGregor Ross Ross had
served as a civil servant in Kenya in
1931
gadi was in England for the second
Indian Round Table Conference late in
the year in October Andrews and Ross
arranged a meeting between Kenyatta and
Gaudi before Gandhi left to return to
India they they brought gaudy up-to-date
on the African political activity in
Kenya and at the end of the meeting gadi
wrote and signed a message in Kenyatta's
1931 diary it reads quote truth and
non-violence can deliver any nation from
bondage under these lines
Kenyatta wrote meeting with Matt magadi
followed by his full signature Jomo
Kenyatta
the influence of the Indian independence
movement and India's independence itself
was a major factor or thinking and
values of all the Kenyan Indians in the
following decades and it was also a
major factor
in the African independence movements of
the 40s 50s 60s and Nelson Mandela
writing on gaudí after his release in
1991 1990 and thereafter wrote that
godis influence remained throughout the
60s on the continent
gadi never went back to africa over the
years that followed although it did not
fully but not wholly leave his thoughts
in 1926 writing he said there is a
strong tie binding the colonial born
Indian to me and this was evidenced also
by what President Obama recently
referred to as God is and I quote
attention to the marginalized voices in
Africa this was of course a reference to
the Tamil labor which he found in 1893
and and that helped God II says
President Obama gather a movement that
moved out I'm sorry that drove out the
world's most successful Empire and so
the influence of gaadi remained constant
there was such a tie in 1939 he wrote a
letter to his old friend in South Africa
velji well.she keshavjee and he writes
in Gujarati and he starts the letter if
I make conveyed in Gujarati first he
says Morel keshavjee and it's very
difficult to translate that in English
it doesn't mean by keshavjee it doesn't
mean my dear keshavjee
they mean different things it was
something very close between them and he
writes and that's very poignant start
Andy Rennick writes its 1939
I have kept your letter of 13th of
August 1938 today I was going through my
old correspondence in the Train
when I came across your letter you have
rightly said that the situation here is
very grave he's writing from tsubame t
from Warda believe me I'm the same
person as I was there I am prepared to
achieve hindu-muslim unity even if I
have to die what can I say about the
situation there in South Africa as I
cannot guide our brethren from here I
keep an eye on your situation all the
time certainly write to me god bless you
blessings from Babu Babu Sarah Graham
Martha it is not only a wistful recall
of old friends but also for a recall of
a time when politics were simpler for
him and he had led against and fought
external enemies while now deeper
divisions and partitions from within
were tearing at his life's work this was
also reflected in another letter that he
wrote in 1942 a correspondent in Misaka
this is what he wrote to Abdullah is
smile and advocate practicing in a small
town in Uganda My dear Ismail 23rd March
1940 I promised to send you a message
here it is I hope that in East Africa at
least you will never allow the communal
poison to kill society the Friends of
the Students Federation never wrote to
me you're sincerely MK Gandhi it is a
message that is as applicable to East
Africa now as it was to India
and finally though he never went back to
Africa in a way he did on gardius death
in 1948 the connection with Africa was
reaffirmed from his cremation at Raja in
Delhi a part of the ashes the major
portion of which of course were cast in
the Ganges were also to be taken to
South Africa they were to be carried by
mr. Suraj Jerusalem G both Suraj ji and
his father referred to in Gandhi's South
African writings as the Parsee Rustom G
were political associates and close
family friends of Gandhi on the way from
Bombay to South Africa the steamer
carrying mr. Suraj dearest mg ducked in
Mombasa for several days he was met
there by his close friend mr. Jamshed
Baron ji of Nairobi mr. Baron ji
remembered later when restante ship
stopped at Mombasa on the way back how
much was paid to the ashes in Mombasa
the urn was then brought to Nairobi and
placed in the Desai Memorial Hall for
one day where again the public including
the then governor of Kenya Sir Philip
Mitchell paid their respects upon the
return of the urn to Mombasa mr.
Barringer quested mr. Aslam ji to allow
part of the ashes to be left behind in
East Africa so that they could be
immersed at the source of the Nile mr.
Rastogi agreed to this accordingly some
of the ashes were then put in a new urn
and left behind while mr. stingy
proceeded to South Africa with the
remainder there those ashes were
immersed at the confluence of the Indian
Ocean and the Atlantic Ocean outside
Cape Town the new urn containing the
ashes left behind at Mombasa was then
taken to Nairobi and from there the
ashes were taken by road to Uganda soon
other
cars joined the convoy and the journey
took seven days instead of two because
at every Township on the way people stop
the convoy and gathered to pay their
respects and the procession had to stop
each time upon finally reaching Kampala
there was again a formal ceremony of
homage attended also by the governor of
Uganda the ashes were then taken to
ginger on the 14th of August 1948 on the
eve of the first anniversary of
Independence before a huge crowd
gathered on the riverbank the ashes of
Martin agathi were immersed in the
source of the River Nile the honour of
immersing the ashes in the Nile was
given to mr. Ram Bela Sarah a highly
respected social worker of great
integrity as befitting godis ideals of
public service and so again by another
unlikely turn of events God ease close
association with East Africa was again
echoed in that last journey through
Kenya and Uganda and in searching about
Gandhi
Indian history in Kenya and Kenyan
history
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right thanks very much for your talk
that was absolutely fascinating I had a
question about how membership of Empire
is being conceptualized and it was quite
interesting to me that one is using the
idea of Indian settlers subtler being a
word that's often simply used in a sort
of racially bounded way to only apply to
white settlers and I'm curious about the
ways in which Indian people think of
themselves as agents of Empire who are
carrying forward the sort of Imperial
izing mission and also equally this
language I think you quoted Andrews
saying that the question of parity for
Indians will be decided in the colonies
what seems to suggest to some extent
that India is being imagined as some
kind of sub imperial Metropole in
relation to the African colonies so if
you could just address some of these
issues and maybe even the possibility of
comparison with spaces such as Palestine
where you have other non-white
populations becoming settler population
thank you
sure certainly the settlers in in the
indian settlers in south africa in in
east africa in trinidad etc were not
carrying forward and imperial icing
mission at all they they were they came
there in in a form which was very close
to the system that they had replaced of
slavery and the conditions in which the
indentured labour lived in Fiji and and
for example in South Africa were were
not conditions which which gave them any
sympathy with their rulers they were
they did not themselves use the term
settlers ironically it's gaudy who
constantly pointed out that the Indians
were in Kenya long before the British
settlers came in and that is where he
uses the term settlers in in respect of
the Indian immigrants the settlement of
Indians in East Africa breaks up into to
one part the early merchants seasonal
visitors and later permanent residents
there and secondly the indentured
laborers and the difference is that the
first merchant settlements were only at
the coast
although alladhina Vishram had a huge
empire inland as well of shops
the second was the second wave was what
took the Indians up country and that was
the indentured labor used in the
building of the railways so that they
they do not see themselves and this has
to be separated because there are a lot
there is a lot of Indian writing that
praises the Empire both in India in East
Africa or anywhere else South Africa and
so on and you used to to place it within
its time frame and say what was the the
political thinking of the person who's
writing and was this reflective of the
position of the whole of the settlers so
that there are people who seek to use
those not only to say that theory that
the writers are praising the Empire but
that they are praising the Empire for
using let's say tamil labor or Punjabi
labor for building the railway or the
that these are people who who can who
flourish under the Empire and you have
supervisors you have Capo's who threw
out all all ruling groups using such
persons so it is not that membership of
the Empire was to distinguish between
even lower status which was you are a
nobody in the Empire and you will do
what we say if we say build a canal
you build a canal if we say we want
cheap labor for white settlers or sugar
plantations in the West Indies that is
you and so on so this is an attempt to
say that you cannot on the one hand have
a king Emperor who is saying I rule for
I'm a benevolent and I rule this large
the largest empire etc for the good of
the people and yet you say it is
perfectly alright if to discriminate
against these people in and say the
well-to-do among them cannot buy farms
which whites should have or that
somebody who is for example Neru
heroin Cambridge had no vote in India
when he came back so are you going to
apply the the concept that this is a
state of affairs which the Empire is has
is actually practicing no it was not are
you going to apply roads Cecil Rhodes
things for all civilized men right so
there are no women no definition of
civilized and how are you going to to
judge who should be treated how and that
is why later on in I'm sorry that I
didn't touch upon the thing but both
Andrews and and Gandhi who had never
spoken in these ways come to to define
the disappointment not only of the
Devonshire declaration but of a whole
series of conduct as the racial I'm
sorry as the colour problem and so the
and that is what reading is saying
humiliation and so on so this is how you
you say I am a lawyer a Gujarati lawyer
in South Africa and I'm addressing a
British government which says that we
uphold reason we uphold justice and we
uphold the Equality of all the subjects
under the Emperor and Gandhi says well
show us and so he we are also members of
this Empire that is how so that you get
you get language which is consistent
with what they were thinking then and
they moved away from this eventually and
the devonshire declaration was a blow to
to anybody who seriously thought that
this was the only way and also if I if I
may say so which I didn't exactly at the
time it the The Devonshire Declaration
and the Kenya in the Indians work
struggle day and Congress and gaudí
putting support there did not in any way
stop the the Indian struggle from
carrying on exactly at that time 1921 23
the Khilafat movement is on the the
first major satyagraha 1921-22 which he
then called off what's going on exactly
at that time so it is clear that gandhi
had not been to Yale he was quite
capable of chewing gum and conducting
three or four campaigns all at the same
time
section which is on the second floor I
didn't is being served please do try to
come up and and dr. fellows he'll also
be here tomorrow and we speaking to some
of the students at the African Council I
plant so then you should talk listen to
us talk about current events in Kenya
[Applause]
[Music]